aquele menino jogando bola morreu
não pode ser foi mais uma a bandidagem a
cdu e essa bandidagem alheia
e o estado a negligenciar a
é parte do jogo pra mim mata e fingido e
bate e fingem não ver machuca e tem
gente não vê insulta e finge que não vê
remada e finge que não vê hepatite e
desde que não vê machuca e tem gente que
não tem insulta e fingir que não é
importa matar mais um beijo em bater
cabelo duro aquele do olho escuro é só o
neném não é matar mais um pouquinho
basta aquele cabelo duro aquele do uno
escuro é só o neguem não é não é
não é
aquela menina ali na esquina boca não
pode ser foi estudar ea bala perdida foi
acertar a sua pele preta que é a
sentença para condenar
e parte do jogo para nos matar
e tem gente que não vê e parte e tem
gente que não vê machuca e tem gente que
não tem insulta e fingir que não tem
mata e finge que não vê e bate beijo que
não vê machuca e tem gente que não tem
insulta e finge que não vê r manda matar
mais um delírio mas aquele cabelo duro
aquele do olho escuro é só de quem não é
matar mais bata ele cabelo
aquele do olho escuro é só nem quem não
é batalhar mais um bequinho mas aquele
cabelo duro aquele do olho escuro é só
um de quem não é matar mais um de limpa
aquele cabelo era aquele do olho escuro
é só um de quem não é obrigada
[Aplausos]